Well, my first question is,...
...what was the biggest challenge to make this very new, you know,...
New music.
I think the biggest challenge was to make the transition,...
...of course, from being a classical musician...
...to doing something completely different...
...and forgetting all of the rules that you were told when you were a classical musician.
So, you have to forget everything you've studied, and your way of playing,...
...your way of thinking.
And you have to, kind of, go back to the beginning, and start again.
You have to learn to be very free...
...and you have to learn how to improvise.
And then, I started writing music.
So, it was quite a long journey, and it was very challenging.
But the more challenging it became, the more I was determined to achieve this album,...
...and make this kind of music.
So, how long have you spent to make this?
Well, it's difficult to say because, of course, my last album was eight years ago,...
...which is a very long time.
And I think through all of that process,...
...of course, I was trying then to change my style of playing and learn new things.
So, I think the whole time was, you know, the transitional period.
And if certain things hadn't happened during that time,...
...I don't think this album would have been made in the same way.
And if I'd made it earlier,...
...you know, maybe I wouldn't have known exactly the message I wanted to give as a musician.
So, I think it really happened at the right time.